And this is what it looks like in code.
Firstly, we collect the properties
of the card in a collapsed position.
We expand the card and
collect the properties again.
Next, we figure out the differences and
then we transform the card back.
Because we made this style change
we have to wait a frame for
those style changes to take effect.
Otherwise, if we change them again
the browser would ignore these and
we'd see no animation.
Now we've waited a frame.
We can switch on animations and
remove the invert, transforms, and
our past two changes.
All that property collection,
probably sounds quite expensive and
you may be wondering how
you can afford to do it.
It sounds like a lot, and it is.
I mean, you're doing all
these calculations on demand
whenever a user clicks or
taps on a card.
Well it turns out, I was making use of
the 100 millisecond response window
to do all those experts
of calculations up front.
On a Nexus 5 it took around 70
milliseconds to get everything done,
which is well inside that
100 millisecond boundary.